Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In times of old, when I was new and Hogwarts barely started, the founders of our noble school thought never to be parted. United by a common goal, they had the selfsame yearning to make the world's best magic school and pass along their learning. Together we will build and teach, the four good friends decided. And never did they dream that they might someday be divided.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在很久以前，当我还是个新人，霍格沃茨刚刚起步时，我们这所高贵学校的创始人们曾想过永不分离。他们因共同的目标而团结在一起，怀着同样的渴望，想要建立世界上最好的魔法学校，并将他们的知识传承下去。四位好友决定，我们要一起建设，一起教学。他们从未想过有一天会分道扬镳。
So that, Dominic, was Leslie Phillips, aka The Sorting Hat in Harry Potter and the Order of the Phoenix, written by J.K. Rowling, of course. It came out in 2003. We continue with our look at the origins of Harry Potter, but today we're looking more specifically, aren't we, at the origins of Hogwarts itself, the great school for wizards and witches up in the Scottish Highlands. We ended the last episode with you being very, very sneery and finickety. I don't think sneery. I think you were definitely being sneery. I think wryly sceptical, Tom.
多米尼克，刚才那是莱斯利·菲利普斯（Leslie Phillips），也就是《哈利·波特与凤凰社》中分院帽的配音，当然，原著是J.K.罗琳。该书出版于2003年。我们继续探讨哈利·波特的起源，但今天我们要更具体地看看霍格沃茨本身的起源，不是吗？那所位于苏格兰高地、供男女巫师就读的伟大学校。上一集结束时，你表现得非常、非常刻薄且吹毛求疵。我不觉得刻薄。我觉得你绝对是刻薄。我觉得是讽刺性的怀疑，汤姆。
Sneery, pointing out that there were no castles in Scotland before 1200. Yeah. So therefore Hogwarts couldn't have been built there. Well, why did they need a castle, Tom? I don't know. If you're going to build a school, a castle wouldn't be the obvious, maybe like the medievalists of the Victorian period, they wanted to... Or like the Earl of Cornwall in Henry III's brother, who built Tintagel Castle in Cornwall
刻薄，指出1200年之前苏格兰根本没有城堡。是的。所以霍格沃茨不可能建在那里。好吧，汤姆，他们为什么非要建城堡呢？我不知道。如果你要建一所学校，城堡并不是显而易见的选择，也许就像维多利亚时代的那些中世纪主义者一样，他们想要……或者像亨利三世的兄弟康沃尔伯爵，他在康沃尔建造了廷塔杰尔城堡。
as a kind of ersatz version of what he thought King Arthur would look like, King Arthur's castle. So Hogwarts is meant to have been built in the 9th or 10th century. I think it's a bit vague. And the four founders, Tom, do you know the four founders' names? Slytherin, Gryffindor, Hufflepuff, and whatever the other one is. Ravenclaw. That's just, I mean, you're just naming the houses.
作为他心目中亚瑟王城堡的仿制品。所以霍格沃茨被认为是在9世纪或10世纪建造的。我觉得这有点模糊。还有那四位创始人，汤姆，你知道他们的名字吗？斯莱特林、格兰芬多、赫奇帕奇，还有另一个是什么来着？拉文克劳。那只是，我的意思是，你只是在列举学院的名字。
So it's Rowena Ravenclaw, Salazar Slytherin, Helga Hufflepuff, and Godric Gryffindor. Very implausible mix of names, I think. Again, the searching historical skepticism that you're bringing. From the 10th century. But now there are schools, aren't there, that claim to be that old. So Warwick School is one of them. I think it claims from the 10th century. But now there are schools, aren't there, that claim to be that old. So Warwick School is one of them. I think it claims to be 10th century. I think King's School in Canterbury is claimed to be the oldest. It claims to have been founded by St. Augustine himself in 597. That's right. But these schools have been through,
所以是罗伊纳·拉文克劳、萨拉查·斯莱特林、赫尔加·赫奇帕奇和戈德里克·格兰芬多。我觉得这个名字组合非常不可信。又是你带来的那种刨根问底的历史怀疑论。从10世纪开始。但现在确实有一些学校声称有那么古老。沃里克学校就是其中之一。我想它声称始于10世纪。但现在确实有一些学校声称有那么古老。沃里克学校就是其中之一。我想它声称始于10世纪。我想坎特伯雷的国王学校被认为是历史最悠久的。它声称是由圣奥古斯丁本人在597年创立的。没错。但这些学校已经经历了……
I mean, they're making slightly spurious claims, I think it's fair to say. And also they were not regarded as real public schools for a long time. And also they were not true. They were not regarded as real public schools for a long time. Well, they're cathedral schools, aren't they? Exactly, which is slightly different. So they're schools that are set up as part of the infrastructure of cathedral. So when I went to Rochester, which has the second oldest cathedral in England, founded in 604, I think. So a few years after Augustine founded Canterbury, that also claimed to have a very, very old school dating back to the founding of the cathedral. Oh, and there's one in York, isn't there?
我的意思是，我认为公平地说，他们提出了一些稍微虚假的声明。而且在很长一段时间里，它们并没有被视为真正的公学。而且它们也不是真的。在很长一段时间里，它们并没有被视为真正的公学。好吧，它们是座堂学校，不是吗？没错，这稍微有点不同。所以它们是作为座堂基础设施的一部分而建立的学校。当我去了罗切斯特时，那里有英格兰第二古老的座堂，我想是604年建立的。所以就在奥古斯丁建立坎特伯雷几年后，那所学校也声称拥有一所可以追溯到座堂建立之初的非常、非常古老的学校。哦，约克也有一所，不是吗？
St. Peter's. That's right. But none of these are purpose-built public schools. And some listeners, particularly after we utterly failed to explain this in the last episode, may be wondering, what is a public school? Especially if you're overseas listeners, the fact that a public school is also a private school. A lot of people find that very typically English, i.e. utterly baffling and incomprehensible. So the point of a public school is it's public because it's usually a
圣彼得学校。没错。但这些都不是专门建造的公学。一些听众，特别是在我们上一集完全没能解释清楚之后，可能会想，什么是公学？特别是如果你是海外听众，公学竟然也是私立学校，这事实让很多人觉得非常典型地英式，也就是说，完全令人困惑和费解。所以公学的意义在于它是“公”的，因为它通常是一个……
charitable trust and it's open to anybody as long as they will pay. It's not a private tutor. Well, except that, as we will see, the initial idea is that it be open to poor students who couldn't afford to pay. And it's very, very much rooted in the ideal of Christian charity. And that sense that public schools are simultaneously there to serve people who can pay enormous amounts of money to receive the benefits of the education they offer, while simultaneously laying claim to a moral purpose. I mean, it's there now and it's there right from the very beginning. Well, exactly.
慈善信托机构，只要付得起钱，任何人都可以入学。它不是私人导师。好吧，除了我们将要看到的，最初的想法是它应该向付不起钱的贫困学生开放。它非常、非常深植于基督教慈善的理想之中。那种公学既是为了服务那些能支付巨额费用以获得教育福利的人，同时又声称具有道德目的的感觉。我的意思是，它现在存在，而且从一开始就存在。好吧，确实如此。
That tension has been there from the beginning. So sometimes the critics of public schools will say they've lost sight of their original charitable. The charitable stuff is nonsense. They've lost sight of that. But the truth of the matter is- It was there from the beginning. There has always been a tension and it goes right back to the 14th century.
这种张力从一开始就存在。所以有时公学的批评者会说，它们已经忘记了最初的慈善宗旨。慈善什么的都是胡扯。它们已经忘记了。但事实是——它从一开始就在那里。这种张力一直存在，可以追溯到14世纪。
So you mentioned in the last podcast, Tom, an excellent book called The Old Boys by David Turner, which is probably the best sort of short, single volume history of the public schools. And he says in that, what most historians say, the starting point is really this chap, William of Wycombe. He's born in the mid 1320s and he's a very big figure, isn't he, in 14th century England. So he is part of the court of Edward III. And we talked in the episode we did on the Hundred Years War, how Edward III's reign is a crucial turning point in English history. And so much of what will
所以你在上一期播客中提到了大卫·特纳写的一本好书《老男孩》（The Old Boys），这可能是关于公学最好的简短单卷历史书。他在书中说，正如大多数历史学家所说，起点确实是这个叫威廉·威克姆（William of Wycombe）的人。他出生于14世纪20年代中期，是14世纪英格兰的一位大人物，不是吗？他是爱德华三世宫廷的一员。我们在关于百年战争的那一集中讨论过，爱德华三世的统治是英格兰历史上的一个关键转折点。所以很多将要……
bear fruit, I mean, even down to the use of the English language at the heart of the court, dates back to this period. And he is very an expression of that, because he's not from an aristocratic background. His parents are wealthy peasants. Yes. Actually, the kind of striving, upwardly mobile people who throughout the history of public schools have scrimped and saved to send their sons and occasionally their daughters to these establishments. That's the world that he comes from. He is a very, very academically gifted son of peasants who goes right the way up to the top. He becomes Lord Chancellor, he becomes Bishop of Winchester. And as you say, he comes from this village called Wickham,
结出果实的东西，我的意思是，甚至包括在宫廷核心使用英语，都可以追溯到这一时期。他正是这一点的体现，因为他并非出身贵族。他的父母是富裕的农民。是的。实际上，正是那种奋斗的、向上流动的群体，在公学的整个历史上，他们省吃俭用，把儿子，偶尔还有女儿送到这些机构。这就是他出身的世界。他是一个非常有学术天赋的农民之子，一路攀升到了顶峰。他成为了大法官，成为了温彻斯特主教。正如你所说，他来自一个叫威克姆的村庄，
which is about 10 miles outside Winchester. And anyone who is familiar with public school slang will know that the name that old boys of Winchester school give to themselves is Wickhamists. And I assume it comes from William of Wickham. William of Wickham. Yeah. So he himself probably went to a grammar school in Winchester. I mean, again, to explain the terminology, there were in the 14th century a network of grammar schools across England, and they taught you to read and write, but they also taught you Latin. And if you wanted a job as kind of a bureaucrat, a clergyman, if you wanted to move up through the sort of the literate bureaucracies of England.
距离温彻斯特大约10英里。任何熟悉公学俚语的人都会知道，温彻斯特公学的校友们称自己为“威克姆主义者”（Wickhamists）。我假设这来自威廉·威克姆。威廉·威克姆。是的。所以他本人可能上过温彻斯特的一所文法学校。我的意思是，再次解释一下术语，14世纪英格兰各地有一个文法学校网络，它们教你读写，但也教你拉丁语。如果你想找一份官僚、神职人员的工作，如果你想在英格兰那种识字官僚体系中向上爬。
Or to get to Oxford and Cambridge. Yeah. He makes a splendid comment that a bishop was the first graduate profession in English history. By this point, you could only become a bishop if you'd been to Oxford or Cambridge. And you could only go to Oxford or Cambridge if you'd got the necessary Latin that enabled you to do it. Exactly.
或者想去牛津和剑桥。是的。他有一个精彩的评论，说主教是英格兰历史上第一个研究生职业。到这个时候，你只有去过牛津或剑桥才能成为主教。而你只有掌握了必要的拉丁语才能去牛津或剑桥。没错。
Exactly. So I know we'll be talking a little bit about Latin in this episode. So right from the start, obviously, Latin is essential to the project. And in those days, it's not what we talked about last time, which is a kind of magic, a secret code just for public schoolboys. It's more than that. It's a crucial vocational tool. Well, it's what English is today for, say, international science. To be a scientist,
没错。所以我知道我们这一集会谈论一点拉丁语。所以从一开始，显然，拉丁语对这个项目至关重要。在那个年代，它不是我们上次谈到的那种魔法，不是只给公学男生看的秘密代码。它不仅仅是那样。它是一个关键的职业工具。好吧，就像今天的英语对于国际科学一样。要成为一名科学家，
you have to speak English because that's the language that is carried out in. But most people in England obviously did not go to grammar schools. A lot went to what were called petty schools, which are kind of amateur, informal, run by one teacher, usually one room. They might teach you to count count to read and write um but but no more than that william of wickham obviously is looking at something a bit bigger and actually that why does england have public schools one answer would just be the black death wouldn't it tom the black death strikes when william of wickham is what 28 30 around about then 1348 and as many as half of the population of England,
你必须说英语，因为那是交流的语言。但英格兰的大多数人显然没有上过文法学校。很多人上的是所谓的“小学校”（petty schools），那是一种业余的、非正式的学校，由一位老师经营，通常只有一个房间。他们可能会教你数数、读写，但仅此而已。威廉·威克姆显然在着眼于更大的事情。事实上，为什么英格兰会有公学？一个答案可能就是黑死病，不是吗，汤姆？黑死病爆发时，威廉·威克姆大概28、30岁左右，1348年。英格兰多达一半的人口，
you know, historians disagree about this, but a vast proportion of the population is wiped out. I mean, it does seem to have disproportionately hit England, I think, is the thinking now. Yeah. And basically, the number of parishes remains the same. So you need just as many priests as you had before, but there are far fewer people to fill them. And William of Wickham is very anxious that there aren't enough recruits coming through. And he would be very sensitive to this, wouldn't he? Being from a less wealthy background himself. So the founding charter of Winchester, which he found, many poor scholars engaged in scholastic disciplines who suffering from deficiency, penury and indigence lack and will lack in the future, the proper means for continuing and
你知道，历史学家对此有分歧，但很大一部分人口被消灭了。我的意思是，现在的观点似乎是它对英格兰的打击不成比例地严重。是的。基本上，教区的数量保持不变。所以你需要和以前一样多的牧师，但填补这些职位的人却少得多。威廉·威克姆非常担心没有足够的后备力量。他对此会非常敏感，不是吗？因为他自己就出身于不太富裕的背景。所以他创立的温彻斯特的创始宪章中写道：“许多陷入贫困、匮乏和窘迫的贫困学者，缺乏且将来也会缺乏继续和……”
advancing in the aforesaid art of grammar.." He's not just complaining about that. You think about the portrayal of scholars, say, in Chaucer, who's writing later in the century. Again, there is this assumption that to be a scholar is to be poor, and this is something that William of Wickham is trying to solve. Exactly. He wants to set up an academy, basically, that will produce people for the church and presumably for the very small royal bureaucracy as well. And he sets up two institutions. So one of them is New College Oxford and New Oxford College, which is formally established for the study of theology, canon and civil law and the arts. And the other is he wants to create a feeder school for New College.
“……在上述文法艺术中深造的适当手段。”他不仅仅是在抱怨这个。想想乔叟在那个世纪晚些时候对学者的描写。同样，人们有一种假设，即成为学者就是贫穷，而这正是威廉·威克姆试图解决的问题。没错。他基本上想建立一所学院，为教会，大概也为规模很小的皇家官僚机构培养人才。他建立了两个机构。一个是牛津大学新学院（New College Oxford），正式成立于神学、教会法、民法和艺术的研究。另一个是他想为新学院建立一所预备学校。
And this is Winchester. He sets it up in 1382. It takes its first pupils in 1394. And the sort of religious side of it is there right from the beginning. It's very monastic, isn't it, Tom? It's very austere. It's not just that they didn't have girls, but the only woman, a washerwoman, it's specified in the constitution that she has to be old and ugly. So no beastliness there. Well, the boys have to have a decent what's called a decent tonsure so they have to have a monastic haircut they are told
这就是温彻斯特。他于1382年建立它。1394年招收了第一批学生。宗教方面从一开始就存在。它非常像修道院，不是吗，汤姆？非常简朴。不仅仅是他们没有女生，而且唯一的女性，一名洗衣妇，宪章中明确规定她必须又老又丑。所以那里没有什么兽行。好吧，男生必须有体面的所谓“体面剃度”，所以他们必须留修道院式的发型，他们被告知
they are in school they are only allowed to speak in latin this is rishi sunak's old school by the way for our overseas listeners um the school room is is based on a church that follows an east west axis they follow all the the religious feasts and And the sort of the Spartan aspect of schools, I'm using Spartan, Tom, before you get excited, in its most debased sense. Right, right. But the kind of slightly Freudian slip there, because the issue of whether the asceticism of these schools, which has been a kind of enduring feature of them right the way up, really until about, what, 30 or 40 years ago. The question of whether they are Spartan, i.e. whether they are emulating the example set by the ancient Greeks and Romans in their days of manly heroism, or whether they are following the monastic example,
他们在学校里只准说拉丁语。顺便说一句，对于我们的海外听众，这是里希·苏纳克的母校。教室是基于遵循东西轴线的教堂，他们遵循所有的宗教节日。而学校那种斯巴达式的方面，汤姆，在你兴奋之前，我是在用它最贬义的意义上使用“斯巴达”这个词。对，对。但那是一个稍微有点弗洛伊德式的口误，因为这些学校的禁欲主义是否是它们一直以来的一个持久特征，直到大约，什么，30或40年前。关于它们是否是斯巴达式的，即它们是否在效仿古希腊人和罗马人在他们充满男子气概的英雄主义时代的榜样，还是它们在遵循修道院的榜样，
is actually very, very interesting and important. But at this stage, though, you've got to... I mean, they're completely monastic, yeah. Completely. It's not Spartan. I mean, it's monastic. Yeah. Absolutely. And indeed, the school is open for 70 poor scholars, and it's 70 because Christ in one of the Gospels specifies that 70 apostles will be sent out into the world. But not just poor scholars, though, is it? No, it's not. Right from the start, there is what I think David Turner calls an escape clause in the Winchester Constitution. He says, which runs as follows, we will allow, however, the sons of noble and influential persons, special friends of the said college, up to the number of 10 to be instructed and
实际上是非常、非常有趣且重要的。但在现阶段，你必须……我的意思是，它们完全是修道院式的，是的。完全是。这不是斯巴达式的。我的意思是，这是修道院式的。是的。绝对是。而且，学校确实为70名贫困学者开放，之所以是70，是因为基督在福音书之一中明确指出，将有70名使徒被派往世界各地。但不仅仅是贫困学者，对吧？不，不是。从一开始，温彻斯特宪章中就有所谓的大卫·特纳所说的“逃生条款”。他说，内容如下：“然而，我们将允许，那些高贵和有影响力的人的儿子，即上述学院的特殊朋友，人数不超过10人，可以在同一学院内接受文法教育和……”
informed in grammar within the same college. In other words, there will be some people who are not poor. And right from the beginning, almost every public school tries to sort of, I was going to say wrestle with, but they're not really wrestling with it, are they? They're gleefully exploiting this loophole because rich and powerful people want their sons to be well-educated as well. And of course, William of Wycombe, because he's the Lord, he's Chancellor, he knows lots of... Yeah, he's got favours, hasn he he's got backs to scratch and exactly exactly so he probably is breaking the rules his own rules himself and allowing in uh churchmen
“……知识传授。”换句话说，会有一些人并不贫穷。从一开始，几乎每一所公学都在试图，我本来想说“挣扎”，但他们并没有真正挣扎，不是吗？他们是在兴高采烈地利用这个漏洞，因为富有和有权势的人也希望他们的儿子受到良好的教育。当然，威廉·威克姆，因为他是大法官，他认识很多……是的，他有人情要还，他有后门可以走，没错，没错。所以他可能自己就在打破规则，他自己的规则，允许……
sons or whatever or noble sons or whatever it might be and then a generation or so later winchester gets a competitor that is i think it's fair to say more glamorous would you agree with that tom because it has royal patronage notorious perhaps i mean it's notorious today think it's fair to say, more glamorous. Would you agree with that, Tom? Because it has royal patronage. Notorious, perhaps. I mean, it's notorious today, but it's glamorous in, yes, because it's near Windsor, which of course, Edward III's great castle has been built there. So again, this goes back to the reign of Edward. And so this is founded by Henry VI in 1440. It is the College of Our Lady Mary at Eton. So Eton, the most famous of all British public schools. Henry VI, useless king, would you agree, Tom? Completely, yes. Totally useless, spends too much time praying and thinking about God, not enough time
教士的儿子，或者贵族的儿子，或者其他什么人进来。然后大约一代人之后，温彻斯特有了一个竞争对手，我认为公平地说，它更迷人，你同意吗，汤姆？因为它有皇家赞助。也许是臭名昭著，我的意思是，它今天臭名昭著，但它在……是的，因为它靠近温莎，当然，爱德华三世的伟大城堡就是建在那里。所以这又回到了爱德华的统治时期。所以这是亨利六世在1440年建立的。这就是伊顿公学，圣母玛利亚学院。所以伊顿，所有英国公学中最著名的一所。亨利六世，无能的国王，你同意吗，汤姆？完全同意，是的。彻底无能，花太多时间祈祷和思考上帝，没有花足够的时间
hammering rivals or what kings should be doing. So he sets this up in direct imitation of Winchester. He actually poaches Winchester's headmaster, William Wainfleet, to come and basically set up Eton for him. I mean, it's such a copy, isn't it? Because just as Wickham had set up New College in Oxford to be the place that Winchester feeds, so Henry VI sets up King's College in Cambridge to fulfill the same role. Yes, exactly. And because of the royal patronage, that means that Eton from the start has an extra layer of glamour and sort of prestige. I mean, Winchester was prestigious in its own way, but Eton goes one step beyond that because it's the king. And you get very aspirational kind of members of the gentry who are keen.
去打击竞争对手，或者做国王应该做的事情。所以他直接模仿温彻斯特建立了这所学校。他实际上从温彻斯特挖走了校长威廉·韦恩弗利特（William Wainfleet），来为他建立伊顿。我的意思是，这简直是抄袭，不是吗？因为正如威克姆在牛津建立了新学院作为温彻斯特的输送地一样，亨利六世也建立了剑桥大学国王学院来发挥同样的作用。是的，没错。而且因为有皇家赞助，这意味着伊顿从一开始就多了一层魅力和声望。我的意思是，温彻斯特有它自己的声望，但伊顿更进一步，因为它是国王建立的。而且你会得到非常有抱负的绅士阶层成员，他们很热衷。
So a good example is the Catesby family from Northamptonshire. People who are interested in Richard III will know that William Catesby was one of his kind of chief cronies. So the Catesbys are very keen to send their boys to Eton because they think it's obviously a way up and a way to get the attention of the king. The detail that I loved about the forms in Eton is that, and I'm quoting here from David Turner's book, each form at Eton had an official dunce known as the custos, an unenviable title given to the weakest boy in the class who was singled out for testing in front of his peers until he improved and the ignominy passed to another boy. So I can't imagine that would be good for his mental health to be an official form dunce.
所以一个很好的例子是北安普敦郡的凯茨比家族。对理查三世感兴趣的人会知道，威廉·凯茨比是他的一位主要亲信。所以凯茨比家族非常热衷于把他们的儿子送到伊顿，因为他们认为这显然是一条上升通道，也是引起国王注意的一种方式。关于伊顿的班级，我喜欢的一个细节是，我在这里引用大卫·特纳的书，伊顿的每个班级都有一个官方的“笨蛋”，被称为“custos”，这是一个令人羡慕的头衔，给班里最弱的学生，他被挑出来在同龄人面前接受测试，直到他进步，这种耻辱才会传给另一个男孩。所以我无法想象成为官方班级笨蛋对他的心理健康有什么好处。
Do you know how long that went on for? Is that something that's going on in Greyfriars? To this day. Because they have dunces caps don't they surely prince harry would have been the costos wouldn't he no no because people would have been doing his work for him of course so um lots of sort of uh interesting people go to eat and the earl of the future earl of essex and the civil war he went to eat and sir francis fernie who became a barbary pirate yes he did didn't he went to captain hook of course goes to what, who became a Barbary pirate. Yes, he did, didn't he? Captain Hook, of course, goes to Eton. Well, I was about to say, piracy is a big thing for Eton because Captain Hook went to Eton. Captain Hook, well, you probably do if you read the same book, Captain Hook's last words when he's being swallowed by the crocodile in Peter Pan, a floriat etona.
你知道这持续了多久吗？这是《格雷弗莱尔》（Greyfriars）里发生的事情吗？直到今天。因为他们有笨蛋帽，不是吗？哈里王子肯定会是那个“custos”，不是吗？不，不，因为人们会替他完成作业，当然。所以，嗯，很多有趣的人去了伊顿，未来的埃塞克斯伯爵，在内战中，他去了伊顿，弗朗西斯·弗尼爵士，他后来成了巴巴里海盗，是的，他确实去了，不是吗？胡克船长，当然去了……谁后来成了巴巴里海盗。是的，他确实去了，不是吗？胡克船长，当然去了伊顿。好吧，我正要说，海盗对伊顿来说是一件大事，因为胡克船长去了伊顿。胡克船长，好吧，如果你读过同一本书，你可能会知道，胡克船长在《彼得·潘》中被鳄鱼吞掉时的遗言是“Floreat Etona”（伊顿繁荣）。
So no wonder people hate Eton, this sense of a mighty elite going to this glamorous school founded by a king. There have been periodic demands that the whole system be closed down and Eton be abolished. But again, I was amused to see that the very first person who wanted to abolish Eton was actually Edward IV, who deposed Henry VI and became king. In 1463, he sent in a petition to the Pope to close it down because, of course, Eton was a religious foundation. And he was foiled by backstairs lobbying by old Etonians. So there really is nothing new under the sun. Yeah, Warwick the Kingmaker's brother, George Neville, who was Archbishop of York.
所以难怪人们讨厌伊顿，这种强大的精英阶层去这所由国王建立的迷人学校的感觉。一直有周期性的要求，要求关闭整个系统并废除伊顿。但同样，我很有趣地发现，第一个想废除伊顿的人实际上是爱德华四世，他废黜了亨利六世并成为了国王。1463年，他向教皇提交了一份请愿书，要求关闭它，因为当然，伊顿是一个宗教基金会。但他被老伊顿人的幕后游说挫败了。所以太阳底下真的没有新鲜事。是的，沃里克“造王者”的兄弟乔治·内维尔，他是约克大主教。
Eton had been bribing him. They'd been sending him gifts and he lobbied. He was able to lobby for Eton to be spared. They, therefore, did confiscate a lot of Eton's lands. So I think it's fair to say that the Yorkists are not highly regarded even now. God, imagine how much richer they'd be if they'd kept all those lands. I know. I know. Those are the two most famous schools, but they're not the only schools. So by the 16th century, there are other kind of prototypical public schools being founded. Probably the most influential is a school
伊顿一直在贿赂他。他们一直在给他送礼物，他进行了游说。他成功地游说伊顿免于被关闭。他们因此没收了伊顿的大量土地。所以我认为公平地说，约克派即使在现在也不受高度评价。天哪，想象一下如果他们保留了所有那些土地，他们会富有得多。我知道。我知道。这是两所最著名的学校，但它们不是唯一的学校。所以到了16世纪，还有其他类型的原型公学正在建立。可能最有影响力的是一所
called Merchant Taylor School, which is set up by most influential is a school called Merchant Taylor School, which is set up by a livery company, the Merchant Taylors, one of a guild. And the Merchant Taylors is the first school that had the idea. We talked a lot about Dr. Arnold and the Victorian kind of sport and all that stuff in the last podcast. Merchant Taylors is the first school in Britain that has the idea of actually having a vaguely rounded education. And that includes sport, doesn't it? So he'd be massively in favour of Quidditch. They would be in favour of Quidditch.
叫“商人裁缝学校”（Merchant Taylor School）的学校，它是由……最有影响力的是一所叫“商人裁缝学校”的学校，它是由一个行会公司，商人裁缝行会建立的。商人裁缝学校是第一所拥有这种想法的学校。我们在上一期播客中谈了很多关于阿诺德博士和维多利亚时代的体育运动等等。商人裁缝学校是英国第一所拥有真正进行某种全面教育想法的学校。这包括体育，不是吗？所以他会非常支持魁地奇。他们会支持魁地奇。
So they were copying that from a school in Italy, in Mantua, where the boys were encouraged to do exercise and to play music and so on. This is the beginnings of, I guess, Renaissance humanism, isn't it? You want to be a Renaissance man. So teach Sprezzatura, the art of being a dashing figure who can speak Greek, but also joust. So the archetypal figure of that is Philip Sidney, isn't it? Who's an old boy of Shrewsbury, which has been founded in 1560. Your neck of the woods vaguely. Yes. Yeah. I grew up not far from Shrewsbury. And Shrewsbury was one of the great public schools of England. But going back to Merchant Taylor, so Merchant Taylor,
所以他们是从意大利曼图亚的一所学校抄袭来的，那里的男孩被鼓励锻炼、演奏音乐等等。这是文艺复兴人文主义的开端，不是吗？你想成为一个文艺复兴人。所以教“Sprezzatura”（从容不迫的艺术），成为一个既能说希腊语又能比武的潇洒人物的艺术。所以这方面的原型人物是菲利普·西德尼，不是吗？他是什鲁斯伯里学校的一名老校友，该校成立于1560年。你家乡附近。是的。是的，我在离什鲁斯伯里不远的地方长大。什鲁斯伯里是英国伟大的公学之一。但回到商人裁缝学校，所以商人裁缝学校，
they would do an awful lot of dancing, wrestling, football, and drama, particularly big on drama. So they did a school play for the Royal Court four times. God, imagine that, having to go and watch that. Oh, yeah. Well, Thomas Kidd, Elizabethan kind of actor, dramatist, he was a Merchant Taylor's old boy. So this tradition, Tom, endured and maybe still endures because do you know who else went to Merchant Taylor's? Boris Karloff, Frankenstein, the totemic
他们会做大量的舞蹈、摔跤、足球和戏剧，特别是对戏剧非常重视。所以他们为皇家宫廷演过四次校剧。天哪，想象一下，不得不去看那个。哦，是的。好吧，托马斯·基德，伊丽莎白时代的演员、剧作家，他是商人裁缝学校的老校友。所以这个传统，汤姆，一直延续，也许现在还在延续，因为你知道还有谁去了商人裁缝学校吗？鲍里斯·卡洛夫，弗兰肯斯坦，20世纪的图腾式
Frankenstein of the 20th century was a Merchant Taylor's old boy. Well, it's kind of interesting, isn't it? Because there's another school that is also a feeder for great dramatists, which is Westminster, a school founded right next to the palace of Westminster. And it's still there to this day. And a boy who goes there is called Ben Johnson. And he's the son of a builder, a manufacturer of bricks. So again, this kind of recognizable, the upwardly mobile man who's self-made, wants to improve his son. Ben Johnson goes to Westminster and he goes on to become Shakespeare's great peer, rival, companion. So actually, when you look at the famous names of Elizabethan and 17th century literature, a lot of them have gone to public
弗兰肯斯坦就是商人裁缝学校的老校友。好吧，这很有趣，不是吗？因为还有另一所学校也是伟大剧作家的输送地，那就是威斯敏斯特学校，一所建在威斯敏斯特宫旁边的学校。它至今仍在那里。一个去那里的男孩叫本·琼森。他是建筑商、砖块制造商的儿子。所以同样，这种可识别的、向上流动的、白手起家的人，想要提升他的儿子。本·琼森去了威斯敏斯特，后来成为了莎士比亚伟大的同僚、竞争对手、伙伴。所以实际上，当你看看伊丽莎白时代和17世纪文学中的著名名字时，他们中的很多人都上过公学。
school. So we mentioned Sir Philip Sidney, who was a famous poet. Edmund Spencer, who wrote The Fairy Queen. Ben Johnson, we've mentioned. And John Milton, who went to the sixth of the public schools that existed by the 17th century, which is St. Paul's. So that, again, had been a cathedral school that gets kind of converted into a public day school. The first school not to have borders. Well, six of the translators of the King James Bible went to Merchant Taylor's, Tom. So the schools, even at this day, they're very rudimentary. They're educating a tiny, tiny proportion of the population, but already they have an outsized influence. So you mentioned Westminster. Westminster is the big school of the 17th century.
所以我们提到了菲利普·西德尼爵士，他是一位著名的诗人。埃德蒙·斯宾塞，他写了《仙后》。本·琼森，我们提到了。还有约翰·弥尔顿，他去了17世纪存在的六所公学之一，即圣保罗学校。所以那又是一所座堂学校，被改造成了一所公立走读学校。第一所没有寄宿生的学校。好吧，钦定版圣经的六位翻译者去了商人裁缝学校，汤姆。所以这些学校，即使在今天，它们也非常基础。它们教育的人口比例极小，但它们已经产生了巨大的影响。所以你提到了威斯敏斯特。威斯敏斯特是17世纪的大校。
So the list of alumni, extraordinary. John Dryden, Robert Hook, John Locke, composer Henry Purcell, the blood transfusion pioneer Richard Lauer, the headmaster of Westminster, Richard Busby. He also taught Sir Christopher Wren privately. And he's an astonishing figure, isn't he? Because he is very much a vicar of Bray figure, that he moves with the changing currents of the time. So he is appointed headmaster of Winchester in 1638, just before the convulsive decade that will see England collapse into civil war. He remains in post throughout the civil war, throughout the Commonwealth, and well into the restoration. And he finally dies in 1695.
所以校友名单，非同寻常。约翰·德莱顿、罗伯特·胡克、约翰·洛克、作曲家亨利·珀塞尔、输血先驱理查德·劳尔、威斯敏斯特校长理查德·巴斯比。他还私下教过克里斯托弗·雷恩爵士。他是一个令人震惊的人物，不是吗？因为他非常像“布雷的牧师”（Vicar of Bray）式的人物，他随着时代的变化而改变。所以他在1638年被任命为温彻斯特校长，就在英格兰陷入内战的动荡十年之前。他在整个内战、整个共和时期以及复辟时期一直担任校长。他最终死于1695年。
Yeah, incredible, incredible record. Now, one thing people may be wondering is what about girls? Typical Reston's history, they haven't mentioned the girls. The truth of the matter is we haven't really talked about girls because there weren't really many girls' schools. There were nunneries that had schools attached, school rooms where they would teach rich people's daughters, but there was far less emphasis on the education of girls in this point, obviously, than education of boys. Dominic, I know you're a big fan of the Reformation, but the Reformation was terrible for girls' education. So among the religious institutions that were closed down in the Reformation was Barking Abbey,
是的，令人难以置信，令人难以置信的记录。现在，人们可能想知道的一件事是女生呢？典型的《历史的余味》，他们没提到女生。事实是，我们没有真正谈论女生，因为当时并没有多少女子学校。有一些附带学校的修道院，在那里他们会教富人的女儿，但在这一点上，对女生教育的重视程度显然远低于对男生的教育。多米尼克，我知道你是宗教改革的忠实粉丝，但宗教改革对女生的教育来说是可怕的。所以，在宗教改革中被关闭的宗教机构中，有巴金修道院（Barking Abbey），
which reached right the way back to the beginnings of Christianity in England, and has been described by Eleanor Parker, who writes a brilliant blog called Clark of Oxford, as the leading centre of female scholarship in the Middle Ages. Continuous tradition of female scholarship going right the way back to the early middle ages all closed down by henry the eighth yeah so from that point onwards what girls schools there are tend to emphasize what they see as kind of wifely arts you know needlework music if they teach a language it's not latin it's french and obviously french for long for centuries seen as an
它一直追溯到英格兰基督教的开端，被埃莉诺·帕克（Eleanor Parker）描述为中世纪女性学术的领先中心，她写了一个叫“牛津书记员”（Clark of Oxford）的精彩博客。女性学术的连续传统一直追溯到中世纪早期，全都被亨利八世关闭了。是的，所以从那时起，存在的女子学校倾向于强调他们所认为的所谓“妻子艺术”，你知道，针线活、音乐，如果他们教一门语言，那不是拉丁语，而是法语。显然，几个世纪以来，法语一直被视为成为淑女的重要组成部分，而那个传统实际上一直持续到20世纪。所以即使在20世纪中期，女子学校的学术能力通常也远不如……或者甚至不是，坦率地说，20世纪的男子公学学术能力也不是很强，但女子学校在教授我们所谓的传统科目方面付出的努力要少得多，因为他们特别强调音乐。你谈到了淑女，当然，淑女的对应物是绅士。但我认为，在我读大卫·特纳的书之前，我没有充分意识到的一件事是，实际上这些公学的社会阶层，在16世纪到17世纪并不是贵族化的。而真正改变这一点的，只是理查德·巴斯比领导下的威斯敏斯特的明星效应。但同样，我想威斯敏斯特成为了一个即使是贵族的主要成员也乐于送儿子去的地方，因为它靠近威斯敏斯特的皇家住所。是的。你确实看到了一些公学作为成功门户的迹象。例如，当沃波尔在18世纪初成为首相时，他的11人内阁中，有3人上过威斯敏斯特，总共有7人上过公学。所以西奥，我们在聊天室里的制片人说，
important part of kind of being a lady and that tradition lasts right through into the 20th century actually so even in the mid-20th century girls schools are generally much less academically high-powered than or not even i mean frankly the boys public schools are not very academically high-powered in the 20th century but the girls schools make far less effort to teach what we'd call the traditional subjects because they're emphasising particularly music. And you talked about ladies, and of course the counterpoint of a lady is a gentleman. But I think one of the things that I hadn't properly appreciated until I read David Turner's book is that actually the social class of these public schools, it's not aristocratic throughout the 16th into the 17th century. And it's really only the star
贵族会在家教育他们的孩子吗？他是对的。总的来说，如果可以的话，你会请一位私人导师。对于17世纪、18世纪初的许多人来说，公学是一个失败的选择。如果负担得起，最好请一位私人导师。所以人们对这些学校的评价是，第一，他们太快打孩子了。学校的理事们经常因为校长对藤条或桦木条过于热衷而责骂他们。第二件事是，所有这些学校都非常、非常腐败。
power of Westminster under Richard Busby that changes that. But again, I guess that Westminster becomes a place where even the leading members of the aristocracy are happy to send their sons because of its proximity to the royal residence in Westminster. Yeah. You do have some signs of public schools being a gateway to success. So, for example, when Walpole becomes prime minister at the beginning of the 18th century, of his 11-man cabinet, three of them have been to Westminster, seven of them in total have been to public school. So Theo, our producer in the chat, is saying,
所以他们总是做一些事情，比如……所以校长……校长是为了赚钱。所以校长经常会做的是，他们会搬出自己的房子，这样他们就可以把房子塞满男孩并赚取利润，而且他们会尽可能多地解雇员工，因为他们不想付钱给他们。所以有这些。另一件事是，实际上教育很糟糕。你提到了弥尔顿。弥尔顿说，他花了七八年时间仅仅是为了拼凑出那些悲惨的拉丁语和希腊语，而这些本来可以很容易、很愉快地在一年内学会。
would aristocrats homeschool their children? And he's right. By and large, you would, if you could, get a private tutor. And for a lot of people in the 17th, early 18th century, the public schools are a bit of a failure option. If you can afford it, it'd be much better to get a private tutor. So the things that people say about these schools are, one, they are much too quick to beat the children. The governors of the schools and whatnot are often telling off the headmasters for being far too enthusiastic with the cane or with the birch. The second thing is that all these schools are very, very corrupt.
佩皮斯，塞缪尔·佩皮斯，他去了圣保罗学校。他在圣保罗的教育太糟糕了。我发现这是一个令人震惊的事实，佩皮斯尽管在海军部担任高级公务员，但他直到29岁才学会乘法。但这对于威斯敏斯特校长理查德·巴斯比来说也是如此。他将数学引入了课程，还有现代东方语言和各种各样的东西，但他自己也不会乘法。所以难怪学校的账目那么糟糕。是的。所以这些学校实际上，当你进入18世纪时，这些学校，直到今天仍被视为英国贵族上层阶级身份的支柱。它们是腐败、无能的代名词。
So they are always doing things like... So the amount that the headmaster is... The headmaster is out to make a profit. So quite often what the headmaster will do is they will move out of their own house so they can stuff the house with boys and make a profit, and they'll sack as many of the staff as they can because they don't want to pay them the money. So there's that. And the other thing is actually the education is quite bad. You mentioned Milton. Milton, he said he spent seven or eight years merely in scraping together so much miserable Latin and Greek as might be learned otherwise easily and delightfully in one year.
还有一件事，我们应该在下半场讨论，汤姆，我觉得非常有趣，那就是它们暴力得令人难以置信。它们确实如此。所以我们现在休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看这些公学中暴力的惊人故事。当我提到暴力时，这不仅仅是学生对学生的行为。这是学生对老师的行为，偶尔还有学生对民兵的行为。所以我们休息后见。
Peeps, Samuel Peeps, he went to St. Paul's. His education at St. Paul's was so bad. I found this a staggering fact that Pepys, even though he worked as a senior civil servant in the admiralty, he didn't learn how to multiply until he was 29. But that's true of Richard Busby as well, the headmaster of Westminster. He introduces mathematics into the curriculum and modern oriental languages and all kinds of things, but he couldn't multiply either. So no wonder the accounts for the school were so bad. Yeah. So the schools were actually, as you enter the 18th century, these schools, which are now to this day regarded as kind of pillars of British aristocratic upper-class identity. They are bywords for corruption, incompetence.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
And one other thing, which we should get into in the second half, Tom, which I find enormously entertaining, is how unbelievably violent they are. They are. So we will take a break now. And when we come back, we will look at the astonishing story of the violence in these public schools. And when I say violent, this isn't just pupil on pupil action. It's pupil on teacher action and occasionally pupil on militia action. So we will see you after the break.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。金斯利走上高台，向留下来的人发表讲话。我们离午夜只有半小时了，所以我们需要迅速行动。霍格沃茨的老师们和凤凰社之间已经达成了一项作战计划。弗立维、斯普劳特和麦格教授将带领战斗小组前往三座最高的塔楼：拉文克劳、天文塔和格兰芬多，在那里他们将有很好的视野，是施展咒语的绝佳位置。同时，卢平、亚瑟和我将带领小组进入场地。我们需要有人组织对学校入口通道的防御。听起来像是我们的工作，弗雷德喊道，指着自己和乔治。金斯利点了点头表示赞同。好了，领导们上来，我们要分配部队。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
所以那是J.K.罗琳的《哈利·波特与死亡圣器》，当然，出版于2007年。它描述了霍格沃茨之战的开始，多米尼克。确实。这是对公学中极端暴力事件的描述。确实如此。这是……所以读到这里的孩子们，当然根据我在桑德布鲁克小学的经验，读哈利·波特的孩子们喜欢学校发生战斗的想法，男孩和女孩们建立路障并准备防御，以及那场伟大的决战。他们喜欢它是因为这种不协调感。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Kingsley had stepped forward on the raised platform to address those who had remained behind. We've only got half an hour until midnight, so we need to act fast. A battle plan has been agreed between the teachers of Hogwarts and the Order of the Phoenix. Professors Flitwick, Sprout and McGonagall are going to take groups of fighters up to the three highest towers, Ravenclaw, Astronomy, and Gryffindor, where they'll have a good overview, excellent positions from which to work spells. Meanwhile, Remus, Arthur, and I will take groups into the grounds. We'll need somebody to organise defence of the entrances of the passageways into the school. Sounds like a job for us, called Fred, indicating himself and George. And Kingsley nodded his approval. All right, leaders up here, and we'll divide up the troops.
你知道，学校会成为战场这个想法对他们来说似乎非同寻常。但事实是，在18世纪，学校经常是战场。在我们在退后一步讨论原因之前，我给你举个例子。温彻斯特公学，我们上次谈到的最古老的学校，那种基础公学，里希·苏纳克的学校。1793年春天，温彻斯特公学的院长，一个叫约瑟夫·沃顿的人，他禁止男孩们参加白金汉郡民兵乐队在温彻斯特座堂广场的演出。他试图改革学校并打击不纪律行为，这是一种方式。他发现其中一个男孩，一个级长，汤姆，
So that is from Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows by J.K. Rowling, of course, published in 2007. And it describes the onset of the Battle of Hogwarts, Dominic. It does. An account of extreme violence in a public school. It does indeed. And this is a bit that, so children reading this, certainly in my experience with Sandbrook Jr., children reading Harry Potter love the idea of a battle taking place in school and the boys and girls kind of building barricades and preparing their defences and the great showdown. And they like it because of the incongruity.
这段文字当然出自J.K.罗琳于2007年出版的《哈利·波特与死亡圣器》。多米尼克，它描述了霍格沃茨之战的开始。确实如此。这是对一所公立学校中极端暴力事件的描述。确实是这样。对于阅读这本书的孩子们来说，根据我在桑德布鲁克初中（Sandbrook Jr.）的经验，孩子们非常喜欢学校里发生战斗、男孩女孩们筑起路障、准备防御并进行大决战的想法。他们喜欢这种情节是因为其中的不协调感。
You know, the idea that a school would be a battleground seems extraordinary to them. But the truth of the matter is that in the 18th century, schools were very often battlegrounds. And I'll give you an example before we kind of pull back and talk about the reasons for it. So Winchester College, the oldest school that we talked about last time, the kind of foundational public school, the Richard Sunak School. In the spring of 1793, the warden of Winchester College, who was a man called Joseph Wharton, he forbade the boys from attending a performance by the Buckinghamshire Militia Band in the Cathedral Close in Winchester. He was trying to reform the school and clamp down on undiscipline, and this was a way of doing it. And he discovered that one of the boys, a prefect no less, Tom,
你知道，学校成为战场对他们来说似乎不可思议。但事实是，在18世纪，学校经常就是战场。在我们要退后一步讨论其原因之前，我先给你举个例子。温切斯特公学，也就是我们上次谈到的最古老的学校，那种公立学校的基石，也就是里希·苏纳克（Richard Sunak）就读的学校。1793年春天，温切斯特公学的院长，一个名叫约瑟夫·沃顿（Joseph Wharton）的人，禁止学生们去温切斯特大教堂广场观看白金汉郡民兵乐队的演出。他当时正试图整顿学校，严厉打击纪律涣散，而这正是他采取的手段之一。结果他发现，其中一个学生，而且还是个级长，名叫汤姆，
had ignored this rule and had gone to hear the band play. And as a punishment, the warden did that thing that public school headmasters love to do, that he punished everybody collectively for the misdeed of this one boy. Now, after he did this, the boys went ballistic. They were told that they weren't going to be allowed out for Easter, for the Easter holiday. They went ballistic and they wrote a letter in Latin to the warden demanding redress and saying he must apologise to them. The warden basically ignored their entreaties. So they launched a rebellion. They armed themselves in the first instance with marbles and they attacked an usher of the school, marbles and clubs. I mustn't forget the clubs.
无视了这条规定，跑去听乐队演奏。作为惩罚，校长做了公立学校校长们最喜欢做的事：因为这一个男孩的过错，他惩罚了所有人。这事儿一出，男孩们彻底炸锅了。他们被告知复活节假期不准外出。他们怒不可遏，用拉丁文给校长写了一封信，要求赔偿并声称他必须向他们道歉。校长基本上无视了他们的恳求。于是他们发动了叛乱。起初，他们用弹珠武装自己，袭击了一名学校的引座员，用的就是弹珠和棍棒。我可不能忘了棍棒。
So marbles kind of like using like sling, slingshot. Yes, exactly. Sort of heavy. Not to bring down cavalry. Well, it would bring down cavalry if necessary. They roll them. You either throw them or roll them. So they threw them at the usher, who was a man called Mr. Goddard. Often the schools would have what were called sergeants or ushers or porters who wouldn't teach, but would be there to enforce discipline. So they were hated figures.
所以弹珠就像是用弹弓一样？是的，完全正确。挺沉的。不是为了打倒骑兵。嗯，如果有必要的话，确实能打倒骑兵。他们把弹珠滚过去。你可以扔，也可以滚。所以他们把弹珠扔向那个引座员，一个叫戈达德先生的人。学校通常会有所谓的军士、引座员或门房，他们不负责教学，只负责执行纪律。所以他们是令人憎恨的人物。
Mr. Goddard is one of these people. Then the boys rampaged through the school, smashing windows. They dragged all the desks into the courtyard and set them on fire. The warden sent them a note. Even at this point, he was a bit livid, Mr. Warden, I have to say, Tom. He asked for a truce, and the boys refused. They occupied the second master's house and blockaded it with chairs and desks, very Battle of Hogwarts. The warden arrived. He was trying to negotiate with the boys. The boys
戈达德先生就是其中之一。随后，男孩们在学校里横冲直撞，砸碎窗户。他们把所有的课桌拖到院子里点火烧了。校长给他们写了张字条。即便到了这个地步，校长还是有点火冒三丈，汤姆，我得说。他请求休战，但男孩们拒绝了。他们占领了第二教师的住所，并用椅子和课桌封锁了它，非常有霍格沃茨大战的既视感。校长赶到了。他试图与男孩们谈判。男孩们
seized him and imprisoned him and held him as a hostage. The next day, the high sheriff of Hampshire arrived and read the riot act. Now, if you read the riot act to a crowd, ordering them to disperse, if they refuse to disperse, they're effectively guilty of treason and you can use the riot act to a crowd ordering them to disperse if they refuse to disperse they're effectively guilty of treason and you can use the militia to fire on them when the high sheriff arrived to read the riot act he found that the boys had blockaded the gates of the school they had armed themselves with swords six sticks stones and clubs some boys now at this point had loaded pistols and were on the kind of ramparts he had to retreat. They'd also torn up the parapet of the building to use as stones to bombard attackers. So he returned the next day
抓住了他，将他囚禁起来作为人质。第二天，汉普郡的高级警长赶到并宣读了《暴乱法》。现在，如果你向人群宣读《暴乱法》命令他们解散，如果他们拒绝解散，他们实际上就犯了叛国罪，你可以利用《暴乱法》命令人群解散，如果他们拒绝解散，他们实际上就犯了叛国罪，你可以动用民兵向他们开火。当高级警长赶到宣读《暴乱法》时，他发现男孩们已经封锁了校门，他们用剑、棍棒、石头和木棒武装了自己，此时有些男孩甚至装填了手枪，站在某种防御工事上，他不得不撤退。他们还拆掉了建筑物的护墙，用作石头来轰炸袭击者。所以他第二天又回来了
with the North Hampshire militia, three companies of the militia. And by this point, several days had gone by and the boys were actually running out of supplies. So they agreed a truce. But the truce only lasted a day because the warden broke the truce by demanding the return of the stolen pistols, which the boys regarded as absolutely outrageous. There was yet another confrontation. And in the end, lots of the boys walked out of the school. And as was so often the case, the governors of the school decided that the headmaster had to go. It was his fault. Yeah. So he ended up losing. And the amazing thing is, because we know the names of the school decided that the headmaster had to go. It was his fault. Yeah. So he ended up losing. And the amazing thing is, because we know the names of the people who led this rebellion,
带着北汉普郡民兵，三个连的民兵。此时，几天已经过去了，男孩们的补给实际上快耗尽了。于是他们达成了一项休战协议。但休战只持续了一天，因为校长打破了协议，要求归还被盗的手枪，男孩们认为这简直是不可理喻。又发生了一次对峙。最终，许多男孩退学了。正如经常发生的那样，学校的理事们决定校长必须走人。这是他的错。是的。所以他最终输了。令人惊奇的是，因为我们知道领导这场叛乱的人的名字，
I looked up what happened to them. John Colborne, he became the governor general of Canada. Sir Lionel Smith, he became the governor of Jamaica. Sir James Charles Dalbiak, he became one of Britain's leading commanders in the Peninsular War. Thomas Silver, another of the boys, he became professor of Anglo-Saxon at St John's College, Cambridge. And Richard Mart, the other leader of the rebels, he became the Bishop of Down. Did you come across Lieutenant General Sir Willoughby Cotton? Oh, he led, was that Marlborough? No, he was a part of the rugby revolt, but he put
我查了查他们的下场。约翰·科尔伯恩，他后来成为了加拿大总督。莱昂内尔·史密斯爵士，他成为了牙买加总督。詹姆斯·查尔斯·达尔比亚克爵士，他成为了半岛战争中英国的主要指挥官之一。托马斯·西尔弗，另一名男孩，他成为了剑桥大学圣约翰学院的盎格鲁-撒克逊语教授。而理查德·马特，叛军的另一位领袖，他成为了唐恩教区的主教。你有没有遇到威洛比·科顿中将？哦，他领导了，那是马尔伯勒吗？不，他是橄榄球起义的一部分，但他镇压了
down a slave uprising in Jamaica. And so that, I think, does kind of open up all kinds of interesting questions about the impact of these kinds of institutions being enrolled in these schools, the organized brutality, the sense that... So Sidney Smith, who was a writer, a priest who had been head boy at Winchester, like Rishi Sunak in the 1780s. And he says that to be a boy at one of these schools is to be alternately tyrant and slave. And you can see these guys are going on and they're dealing with literal slaves. What is the impact of all this on the fabric of British society and the empire that is starting to merge overseas? Well, I think there obviously is a low-level
牙买加的一场奴隶起义。所以，我认为这确实引出了一些关于这些机构的影响、在这些学校注册、有组织的残暴行为、那种……所以西德尼·史密斯，一位作家，一位曾在1780年代担任温彻斯特学校首席男生的牧师。他说，在这些学校里做一个男孩，就是轮流扮演暴君和奴隶。你可以看到这些家伙继续前进，他们正在处理真正的奴隶。所有这一切对英国社会结构以及正在海外兴起的帝国有什么影响？嗯，我认为这显然存在一种低水平的
violence that runs through the whole 18th century at these schools. They are extraordinarily violent institutions, not least because they're actually abysmal institutions. They are extraordinarily ill-funded. The boys have very little to do. So at Eton, for example, you would only have four hours of lessons a day. And in what lessons there are at the schools, they're often taught in freezing cold rooms at Eton. The head of Eton, John Keaton, we talked about them trying to make money by cutting down on staffing costs. He would teach classes of 190 boys, Tom. Yeah. Yeah, because now public schools boast about, you know, it'll be seven students for a teacher. That's the opposite extreme. But the violence of it, so obviously the beatings,
暴力贯穿了整个18世纪的这些学校。它们是非常暴力的机构，不仅因为它们实际上是糟糕透顶的机构。它们的资金极其匮乏。男孩们没什么事可做。所以以伊顿公学为例，你每天只有四个小时的课程。而且学校里仅有的课程，通常是在冰冷的房间里教授的。伊顿的校长约翰·基顿，我们谈到过他们试图通过削减员工成本来赚钱。他会给190个男孩上课，汤姆。是的。是的，因为现在公立学校吹嘘说，你知道，一个老师带七个学生。那是另一个极端。但其中的暴力，显然是殴打，
and it's not just, you know, teachers flogging boys, it's also prefects flogging fags, you know, the boys who- The junior boys, yeah. Have to serve as kind of servants to the senior boys. Oh my God. These stories are mind-boggling. I mean, the sense that you arrive at these schools and you get broken in very hard. So we talked about rugby and Tom Brown arriving and the process of being initiated into these schools. But the hazing rituals that you have in the 18th century at rugby are astonishing. So new boys are made to stand on a table, they have to sing. And if the singing isn't good enough, so this would
而且不仅仅是老师鞭打男孩，还有级长鞭打低年级生，你知道，那些男孩——低年级男生，是的。必须充当高年级男生的仆人。天哪。这些故事令人难以置信。我的意思是，那种你刚到这些学校就被狠狠地“驯服”的感觉。所以我们谈到了橄榄球和汤姆·布朗的到来，以及被引入这些学校的过程。但你在18世纪的橄榄球学校里看到的欺凌仪式令人震惊。所以新来的男孩被迫站在桌子上，他们必须唱歌。如果唱得不够好，那么这对我来说
be very worrying for me, you have to swallow a pail of muddy water that has been mixed with salt, which unsurprisingly, you're vomiting for days afterwards and everyone's having a jolly good laugh about it. I mean, it's kind of eye-bopping. You think that's bad? That is nothing. Listen to this. At Winchester, junior boys were forced to wear what people called tin gloves. And what that was, was that was to toughen up your hands for carrying the frying pans with the older boys' breakfast. So to toughen your hands, you'd be forced to hold a scorching white hot branding stick and to like hold it for as long as possible to give you calluses on your hands
会非常令人担忧，你必须吞下一桶混有盐的泥水，不出所料，你之后会呕吐好几天，而每个人都在为此开怀大笑。我的意思是，这简直让人眼珠都要掉出来了。你觉得那很糟糕？那根本不算什么。听听这个。在温彻斯特，低年级男生被迫戴上所谓的锡手套。那是为了让你的手变硬，好去端高年级男生的早餐煎锅。所以为了让手变硬，你会被迫握住一根烧得通红的烙铁，尽可能长时间地握着它，好让你的手上长出老茧
or eaten eaten tom if you were at start had started at eaten you were taken out into the countryside by the older boys in a big group you were given a 10 yard head start and then pursued by prefects who took pot shots at you with pistols. Yeah. I mean, it's all very eye-opening stuff. And I think it's not surprising that these rebellions that you have, I mean, these are going through the 1790s, which is obviously in France. It's the age of the French Revolution. And there are occasional signs that the boys are influenced by that. So there's 1796, a boy from Merchant Taylor's flies the tricolour over the Tower of London. And there's a rebellion in Winchester and they fly the red cap. That's the rebellion that I was just talking about in 1793. They flew the red revolutionary cap.
或者伊顿，汤姆，如果你在伊顿开始学习，你会和一大群人一起被高年级男生带到乡下，给你10码的领先优势，然后被级长追赶，他们用手枪向你射击。是的。我的意思是，这一切都非常令人大开眼界。而且我认为这些叛乱并不令人惊讶，我的意思是，这些发生在1790年代，显然是在法国。那是法国大革命的时代。偶尔有迹象表明男孩们受到了影响。所以1796年，一名来自商人泰勒学校的男孩在伦敦塔上空升起了三色旗。温彻斯特也发生了叛乱，他们升起了红帽子。那就是我刚才提到的1793年的那场叛乱。他们升起了红色的革命帽。
But I mean, it's not really revolutionary, is it? Because it's about prefects wanting to uphold their power. And again and again, in most of them, it's about boys feeling that their dignity is being infringed. So if a headmaster is brought in who is not of sufficient social standing, they'll rise in rebellion. If prefects feel that their dignity is being infringed by the teachers, again, they'll rise in rebellion. So these are very, very, I mean, one might almost say Tory rebellions rather than Jacobin rebellions. They are, absolutely. So these schools have a very, I mean, one might almost say Tory rebellions rather than Jacobin rebellions. They are absolutely. So these schools have a very, very Tory ethos. I mean, Tory in the old sense. A good way of thinking about the Toryism of the schools or the low level violence is how the boys entertain themselves. So even once you've been accepted
但我的意思是，这并不是真正的革命，对吧？因为这是关于级长想要维护他们的权力。而且一次又一次，在大多数叛乱中，都是关于男孩们觉得自己的尊严受到了侵犯。所以如果引进了一位社会地位不够高的校长，他们就会起来反抗。如果级长觉得自己的尊严被老师侵犯了，他们也会起来反抗。所以这些是非常、非常，人们几乎可以说这是托利党式的叛乱，而不是雅各宾派的叛乱。它们确实是，绝对是。所以这些学校有一种非常、非常托利党的精神。我的意思是旧意义上的托利党。思考这些学校的托利主义或低水平暴力的一种好方法是看男孩们如何自娱自乐。所以即使你已经被录取了
at one of these schools, what do you do to entertain yourself? Mainly you murder animals. Well, in Harrow, that's the school sport is killing the cats of the town. Well, not just that. They would have a thing called twosling. And twosling meant you would equip yourself with a club or stick or something, and you would go out into the countryside and you would beat to death any wildlife that you found. A maubra, the boys would carry what was called a squalor, which was a wooden stick weighted with lead, to kill game, to sort of tramp through the fields. Which presumably shades into poaching. Yes, exactly.
在这些学校之一，你做什么来娱乐自己？主要是杀害动物。嗯，在哈罗公学，学校运动就是杀死镇上的猫。嗯，不仅如此。他们有一种叫“twosling”的东西。Twosling意味着你会装备一根棍子或棒子之类的东西，然后你会走到乡下，把你发现的任何野生动物打死。在马尔伯勒，男孩们会带着一种叫“squalor”的东西，那是一根加了铅的木棍，用来猎杀野味，在田野里践踏。这大概也涉及偷猎。是的，完全正确。
Now, what that suggests is the lack of discipline at these places, which is true to an extent. So the teachers don't have any discipline. What discipline there is, is enforced, as you said, by the boys themselves. So there's a wonderful line, isn't there? I think it's in the David Turner book. It was said that there are only three absolute rulers in the world. The great mogul, the captain of a man of war, and the prefect of hall at Winchester.
现在，这表明了这些地方缺乏纪律，在某种程度上确实如此。所以老师们没有任何纪律。正如你所说，存在的纪律是由男孩们自己执行的。所以有一句精彩的话，不是吗？我想是在大卫·特纳的书里。据说世界上只有三个绝对统治者。伟大的莫卧儿皇帝、战舰舰长，以及温彻斯特学校的宿舍级长。
And so these boys are used to almost kind of self-government. Lord of the flies. It is very Lord of the flies. Because you said earlier in the first half that the head teachers are always looking to economize because they'll make more money that way. And so obviously you cram as many boys in, but you also cut back the number of staff who are looking after them. So you mentioned that the rebellions often happen. They happen at the point where there are kind of reforming headmasters brought in to try
所以这些男孩习惯了某种程度上的自我管理。《蝇王》。这非常像《蝇王》。因为你在上半场说过，校长们总是想方设法省钱，因为那样他们能赚更多钱。所以很明显，你塞进尽可能多的男孩，但也削减了照顾他们的员工数量。所以你提到叛乱经常发生。它们发生在引进改革派校长试图
and sort all this out because they regard this, they're almost kind of proto-Dr. Arnold's who are coming in to try and clean up the schools and stamp out the sort of Tory libertarian violence that has governed the school in the 18th century. So a good example is rugby, 1797. This is another tremendous revolt. So there's a new headmaster called Henry Ingalls, and he wants to sort of clean up the school. He discovers that a boy called Astley has been firing pistols at people. He confiscates the pistol from Astley. Astley regards this as an absolutely disgraceful intrusion on his personal liberty. He reacts to this, Tom. As an English boy.
解决所有这些问题的时候，因为他们认为这……他们几乎是某种原型阿诺德博士，他们进来试图清理学校，铲除18世纪统治学校的那种托利党式的自由放任暴力。所以一个很好的例子是1797年的橄榄球学校。这是另一场巨大的反抗。所以有一位新校长叫亨利·英格尔斯，他想清理学校。他发现一个叫阿斯特利的男孩一直在向人开枪。他没收了阿斯特利的手枪。阿斯特利认为这是对他个人自由的绝对可耻的侵犯。他对此做出了反应，汤姆。像个英国男孩一样。
Yeah, as an English boy, but also with the fervor of a fan of the Second Amendment in the United States, resisting the intrusions of the federal government. So Astley goes and rounds up his mates. They go and smash the windows of the headmaster. The headmaster says, you'll have to pay to replace these windows. Again, the boys regard this as a disgraceful thing for the headmasters. Any decent headmaster should pay for his own smashed windows.
是的，像个英国男孩，但也带着美国第二修正案支持者的狂热，抵制联邦政府的侵入。所以阿斯特利召集了他的伙伴。他们去砸了校长的窗户。校长说，你必须付钱更换这些窗户。同样，男孩们认为这对校长来说是一件可耻的事情。任何体面的校长都应该为自己被砸碎的窗户买单。
So they then get gunpowder and blow up the headmaster's office, which again, they regard as a tremendous jape. Interestingly, you mentioned the French Revolution. They nailed the Declaration of the Rights of Man
所以他们弄到了火药，炸毁了校长的办公室，这同样被他们视为一种巨大的恶作剧。有趣的是，你提到了法国大革命。他们把《人权宣言》钉在了
to the notice board. But I mean, this is the ultimate kind of Tory rebellion. They occupy then a place that rugby was called the Island, which was, please you Tom,
公告栏上。但我的意思是，这是终极的托利党式叛乱。然后他们占领了一个橄榄球学校叫“岛”的地方，那地方，请你汤姆，
a Bronze Age burial ground. Oh, I like that. And they fortified it. Once again, the riot act is read. And once again, soldiers had to be called in, the local militia, to basically surround the boys, besiege them, and eventually the boys had to give up. And this was the thing that you mentioned, Willoughby Cotton. So Willoughby Cotton, he also served in the Peninsular War and in the first Anglo-Afghan
是一个青铜时代的墓地。哦，我喜欢那个。他们加固了它。再一次，《暴乱法》被宣读了。再一次，不得不召集士兵，当地民兵，基本上包围了男孩们，围困他们，最终男孩们不得不放弃。这就是你提到的威洛比·科顿。所以威洛比·科顿，他也参加了半岛战争和第一次英阿
War. And he's basically a real-life flashman, a sort of prototype of a flashman. So these are really quite serious, these revolts. They're not... I just want to throw in another thing. I know that you disagree with me on this, but I think that there is also an element in which the curriculum is influencing this. I know you do.
战争。他基本上是一个现实生活中的弗莱什曼，一种弗莱什曼的原型。所以这些反抗确实非常严重。它们不是……我只是想补充另一件事。我知道你在这点上不同意我，但我认为课程在其中也起到了影响作用。我知道你这么认为。
These are boys who are almost exclusively studying classical texts. It's often said that it's mindless rote learning. To a degree, it is, but you are studying texts that privilege the right of the strong over the weak. And that often, most notoriously, you mentioned Spartan conditions. You'll be reading about Sparta as a kind of ideal in which boys are sent away to houses and brutalized. In the late 19th century, this will be very overt, particularly actually in Scotland where Hogwarts is. So Fetty's school, which Tony Blair went to, was very, very conscious in its emulation of Sparta. It was deliberately set up to be modelled on Sparta. The Edinburgh Academy in the 1800s prefects were renamed Ephors after the boy herds of ancient Sparta. It's not as deliberate as that
这些男孩几乎只学习古典文本。人们常说这是死记硬背。在某种程度上确实如此，但你学习的是那些赋予强者凌驾于弱者之上的权利的文本。而且通常，最臭名昭著的是，你提到了斯巴达式的条件。你会读到关于斯巴达作为一种理想，男孩们被送到房子里并受到残酷对待。在19世纪末，这将非常公开，特别是在霍格沃茨所在的苏格兰。所以托尼·布莱尔就读的费蒂斯学校，在效仿斯巴达方面非常有意识。它被刻意建立为以斯巴达为蓝本。1800年代的爱丁堡学院，级长们被改名为“监察官”，取自古斯巴达的男孩领袖。这并不像那样刻意
in the 18th century, but I do think the experience of reading texts like Thucydides, the famous line in the Melian Dialogue, that the strong do what they can and the weak suffer as they must. I think the impact of reading this in a kind of Lord of the Flies situation, it must have had an effect. What the impact of that is then when you were going off, say, to subdue a slave revolt. If you yourself know what it's like to be chased by people carrying pistols and shot at, if you know what it's like to be beaten with rods that are tipped with lead, it must, I would have thought, psychologically diminish your capacity to feel pity, sympathy, empathy
在18世纪，但我确实认为阅读像修昔底德这样的文本的经历，比如《米洛斯对话》中的名言，强者做他们能做的，弱者承受他们必须承受的。我认为在一种《蝇王》式的情况下阅读这些内容，一定产生过影响。当你去镇压一场奴隶起义时，这会有什么影响？如果你自己知道被携带手枪的人追赶并被射击是什么感觉，如果你知道被铅头棍棒殴打是什么感觉，我想这一定会在心理上削弱你感受怜悯、同情、共情的能力
with the people in distant parts of the world that you were being sent to dominate and subdue. Do you think or not? Well, I agree with you that these are incredibly violent institutions, so they will probably produce- Brutalized people. People who are decent. So Pitt the Elder said, I never knew a boy who was not broken by Eton. It's Pitt the Elder, and he refused to send his son, Pitt the Younger, so he had him homeschooled because he said, I would never put my son through that. The poet Shelley, when he was at Eton. Oh yeah, Shelley baiting. He was, I mean, mobs of hundreds of boys would pursue him through the town shouting,
对你被派去统治和征服的世界遥远角落的人们。你认为呢？嗯，我同意你的看法，这些是极其暴力的机构，所以它们可能会产生——被残酷对待的人。体面的人。所以老皮特说，我从未见过一个没被伊顿公学摧毁的男孩。那是老皮特，他拒绝送他的儿子小皮特去，所以他让他接受家庭教育，因为他说，我绝不会让我的儿子经历那种事。诗人雪莱在伊顿的时候。哦，是的，雪莱被欺负。他，我的意思是，成百上千的男孩在镇上追赶他，大喊着，
the Shelley, the Shelley, the Shelley, kicking things at him and hurling stuff at him because he was interested in science, which they regarded as illegitimate and depraved. He loved a hot air balloon, Shelley. He did. He did. But your point about the classics. So people did read the classics, but they only read very selected, often Virgil. So the Edinburgh Review in 1830 said of Eton's education, it said, the typical Eton boy has not read a single book of Herodotus, Thucydides, Xenophon, Livy, Polybius, or Tacitus. He has not read a single Greek tragedy or comedy. So actually, they weren't reading some of these things. They were just being given bits of Virgil to do again and again. I mean, it depends on the school, but I think at Winchester,
雪莱，雪莱，雪莱，踢他，向他投掷东西，因为他对科学感兴趣，他们认为这是非法和堕落的。他喜欢热气球，雪莱。他确实喜欢。但他确实喜欢。但你关于古典文学的观点。所以人们确实读古典文学，但他们只读非常精选的，通常是维吉尔。所以1830年的《爱丁堡评论》在评价伊顿的教育时说，典型的伊顿男孩没有读过希罗多德、修昔底德、色诺芬、李维、波利比乌斯或塔西佗的一本书。他没有读过一部希腊悲剧或喜剧。所以实际上，他们并没有读过其中一些东西。他们只是被一遍又一遍地给予维吉尔的片段来做。我的意思是，这取决于学校，但我认为在温彻斯特，
definitely they are. And I think at rugby, they are. So I cannot but believe that this is having some kind of an impact. See, I think at rugby, they are. So I cannot but believe that this is having some kind of an impact. See, I think you're overestimating how much they're teaching. I don't think they're doing kind of ancient history or even what we might call literary criticism. But I think the impact of living in a kind of essentially a brutalized institution and reading texts that might provide a degree of legitimacy might kind of clothe it in the sense that you are in a society where this is seen as raising you to be a better soldier, to be someone who can defend the patria or whatever.
他们绝对读了。而且我认为在橄榄球学校，他们也读了。所以我不能不相信这产生了一些影响。看，我认为你高估了他们的教学量。我不认为他们在做某种古代历史，甚至是我们可能称之为文学批评的东西。但我认为生活在一个本质上被残酷对待的机构中，并阅读可能提供某种合法性的文本，可能会以某种方式掩盖它，即你身处一个社会，在这里这被视为培养你成为更好的士兵，成为能够保卫祖国的人，或者其他什么。
I can't help but believe that that must have some impact. Maybe. I personally think the context for this is the general violence of 18th century England, which is a very violent place, a place of mobs and of... I'm not in any way disputing that. I think that the violence is the precondition, but I think that the classics could provide a kind of intellectual garb for it that would then, when you have left school and you are thinking about how life is organized how empires are organized how the strong should behave with regard to the weak that it might provide a kind of kind of intellectual gloss for it that is part of what
我忍不住相信这一定会有一些影响。也许吧。我个人认为这背后的背景是18世纪英国普遍的暴力，那是一个非常暴力的地方，一个充满暴民的地方，而且……我绝不否认这一点。我认为暴力是前提，但我认为古典文学可以为它提供一种知识外衣，当你离开学校，思考生活是如何组织的，帝国是如何组织的，强者应该如何对待弱者时，它可能会为它提供一种知识上的润色，这是阿诺德
arnold is is campaigning against maybe tom i'm i don't know. My favourite school revolt, by the way, is Marlborough, 1851. Because that's late, isn't it? This is the last great revolt. So Marlborough was only about eight years old. It was that classic thing where it had taken on loads and loads of pupils, but didn't really have many teachers. So the description I read, I can't remember whether it was in James Brooke Smith's book or David Turner's, it describes basically for the first eight years, Marlborough just consists of low-level guerrilla warfare. This is, by the way- Like Vietnam. Yeah, like Vietnam or Afghanistan or something. And basically, this all culminates on the 5th
正在反对的一部分。也许吧，汤姆，我不知道。顺便说一句，我最喜欢的学校反抗是1851年的马尔伯勒。因为那是很晚了，不是吗？这是最后一次伟大的反抗。所以马尔伯勒当时只有大约八岁。那是那种经典的情况，它招收了大量的学生，但并没有多少老师。所以我读到的描述，我不记得是在詹姆斯·布鲁克·史密斯的书里还是大卫·特纳的书里了，它基本上描述了前八年，马尔伯勒只包含低水平的游击战。顺便说一句，这是——像越南一样。是的，像越南或阿富汗之类的。基本上，这一切在11月5日达到高潮，
of November, 1851. The headmaster had banned fireworks, bonfire night, because he knew what would happen. But the boys got gunpowder and, according to the thing I read, munitions anyway. Huge explosions racked the school. The school recruited a mob from the town to come and help them attack the teachers. And they destroyed the headmaster's study. And the culminating moment, Tom, which you would not enjoy but I found very amusing, was the headmaster had literally just finished a long handwritten manuscript, a discussion of the plays of Sophocles. No, it didn't go up in smoke. Of course, they dragged it out and set it on fire.
1851年。校长禁止了烟花，篝火之夜，因为他知道会发生什么。但男孩们弄到了火药，根据我读到的东西，无论如何都有弹药。巨大的爆炸震动了学校。学校从镇上招募了一群暴徒来帮助他们攻击老师。他们摧毁了校长的书房。而高潮时刻，汤姆，你不会喜欢但我发现非常有趣的是，校长刚刚完成了一份长篇手写稿，关于索福克勒斯戏剧的讨论。不，它没有化为灰烬。当然，他们把它拖出来点火烧了。
They literally set it on fire. And of course, what happens in all these stories, the governor's then sacked the headmaster. So he loses his essay on Sophocles and he loses his job. He does indeed. And at this point, the public schools, you would think, so this is very early 19th century, the Marlborough one is very late, but by and large,
他们真的把它点火烧了。当然，所有这些故事里发生的事情是，理事们随后解雇了校长。所以他失去了关于索福克勒斯的论文，也失去了工作。他确实失去了。而在这一点上，公立学校，你会认为，所以这是19世纪初，马尔伯勒那次非常晚，但总的来说，
in the early 19th century, you would think the public schools were going to go out of business. So their roles had completely and utterly collapsed. If you take Harrow as an example, Harrow, half the school had burned down because the maths master
在19世纪初，你会认为公立学校要倒闭了。所以他们的入学人数完全彻底崩溃了。如果你以哈罗公学为例，哈罗，半个学校被烧毁了，因为数学老师
had tried to set up his own DIY heating system, which exploded. They were down to like a few dozen boys who would presumably be roaming the land, beating to death badgers or whatever they were doing. And that is the context, what we talked about in the last episode, which is the emergence of Dumbledore, aka Dr. Arnold, who comes in at rugby and says, okay, let's ditch a lot of what happened before. Let's have a completely new ethos. We are going to make these pious, these are academies for Christian gentlemen, which of course, if he tried to do that in the 1790s, people would have laughed at him because the moral codes of kind of Regency England were so different.
试图建立他自己的DIY供暖系统，结果爆炸了。他们只剩下几十个男孩，大概会在乡间游荡，打死獾或者做其他什么事。而这就是背景，我们在上一集谈到的，也就是邓布利多，又名阿诺德博士的出现，他来到橄榄球学校说，好吧，让我们抛弃之前发生的大部分事情。让我们建立一种全新的精神。我们要让这些虔诚的，这些是基督徒绅士的学院，当然，如果他在1790年代尝试这样做，人们会嘲笑他，因为摄政时期英国的道德准则太不同了。
Well, should I tell you what Sheridan said in the 90s about public schools? That nothing short of despotism can establish their government. No principle but fear can support it. Thus, the torturer's rod is introduced. The torturer's rod. It's like the Marky Desai episode all over again, Tom. But as you say, that is the measure of what Arnold achieves. And I suppose in a sense, he's taking it back, isn't he, to its monastic
嗯，我该告诉你谢里丹在90年代关于公立学校说了什么吗？没有什么比专制更能建立他们的政府。除了恐惧，没有原则能支持它。因此，引进了拷问者的鞭子。拷问者的鞭子。这就像萨德侯爵那一集重演，汤姆。但正如你所说，那是阿诺德所取得成就的衡量标准。我想在某种意义上，他正在把它带回，不是吗，带回它的修道院
foundations. The reason that the blurring between the Spartan and the monastic is easy to make when describing public schools is that the monastic becomes Spartan, returns to its Christian foundations, and so on. Obviously, public schools now are a lot less overtly Christian than they were i mean i think they still have chapels don't they and they do they do yeah they're still christian lots of christian foundations but i i mean i would say that what what is happening now to public schools is just a further reiteration of what arnold was doing that they're repackaging moral values in a 21st century garb tom if you were to look at any public school
基础。在描述公立学校时，斯巴达式和修道院式之间的模糊界限很容易划定，因为修道院式变得斯巴达式，回归到它的基督教基础，等等。显然，现在的公立学校比以前公开的基督教色彩少多了，我的意思是，我想他们仍然有礼拜堂，不是吗？他们有，他们有，是的，他们仍然是基督教的，有很多基督教基础，但我，我的意思是，我会说现在公立学校正在发生的事情只是阿诺德所做之事的进一步重申，他们正在用21世纪的外衣重新包装道德价值观，汤姆，如果你看任何公立学校
prospectus or a public school website, they will stress, of course, the facilities, the academic results, and so on. But a key part of the appeal is building character, which is exactly what Arnold was talking about. And actually, you're always being lectured about in the Harry Potter stories, what Dumbledore is always lecturing the children, or indeed what the narrator is lecturing you about, the stories are meant to demonstrate, which is it's about being a team player. It is about a citizen who works for the greater good, all of these kinds of things. That has been part of the ethos of the schools since the 19th century, and it certainly was not the case at all in the 18th century. But it's interesting, isn't it, that one of the gauges of how far cutting-edge
的招生简章或公立学校网站，他们当然会强调设施、学术成果等等。但吸引力的一个关键部分是塑造品格，这正是阿诺德所谈论的。而且实际上，你在哈利·波特故事中总是被说教，邓布利多总是对孩子们说教，或者实际上叙述者在对你说教，这些故事旨在展示，也就是关于成为一名团队合作者。这是关于一个为更大利益而工作的公民，所有这些事情。自19世纪以来，这一直是学校精神的一部分，而在18世纪则完全不是这样。但有趣的是，不是吗，衡量尖端
public morality, elite notions of public morality, have changed is that now even Hogwarts is seen as being regressive, that it's not diverse or inclusive enough. Yeah, JK Rowling's critics say in writing it in the 1990s, she didn't go as far as she should have done. Right, so Dumbledore retrospectively has become gay. Yeah, in the most recent film she should have. And she didn't go as far as she should have done. So Dumbledore retrospectively has become gay. Yeah. In the most recent film, I believe. Fantastic Beasts. And obviously there is a sense that JK Rowling's position on trans issues has disappointed many people who read Harry Potter as a child. Theo is writing in the chat.
公共道德、精英公共道德观念改变了多少的一个指标是，现在连霍格沃茨都被视为倒退，因为它不够多元化或包容性。是的，J.K.罗琳的批评者说，她在1990年代写它时，并没有做到她应该做到的程度。对，所以邓布利多事后变成了同性恋。是的，在最近的电影里她应该做到。而她并没有做到她应该做到的程度。所以邓布利多事后变成了同性恋。是的。在最近的电影里，我相信。神奇动物。显然，J.K.罗琳在跨性别问题上的立场让许多小时候读过哈利·波特的人感到失望。西奥在聊天室里写道。
Murky Waters. I mean, it's not to make a comment on whether it's right or wrong, but it's to say that if public schools are to stay on the cutting edge of morality, even Hogwarts now has been left behind. And so you have, I think it's at St. Paul's, a girls' school at St. Paul's, that they've abolished the post of head girl because it's too binary. Well, the interesting thing is that the schools, which are often perceived, for example, by their critics as being somehow outside, as being escapist kind of redoubts, actually through all their history, they've changed enormously because they're always mirroring society. No, but more than that, establishing the moral parameters for society. That's what Thomas Arnold is doing. He is ahead of the game. He is making England more Christian. It does seem now when you read
浑水。我的意思是，这不是要评论它是对是错，而是要说如果公立学校要保持在道德的最前沿，连霍格沃茨现在都被抛在后面了。所以你有，我想是在圣保罗学校，一所女子学校，他们废除了首席女生的职位，因为它太二元了。嗯，有趣的是，学校，通常被批评者视为某种外部的、逃避现实的堡垒，实际上在它们的整个历史中，它们发生了巨大的变化，因为它们总是反映社会。不，不仅如此，还为社会建立了道德参数。这就是托马斯·阿诺德正在做的事情。他走在时代前列。他正在让英国变得更基督教化。现在读到
Eton College, the most exclusive of all public schools, decolonizing its curriculum and emphasizing equity, I don't really see how a school that is as exclusive as Eton, where you have to pay an absolute fortune to get in there. I mean, to a degree, trumpeting its commitment to equity, there's a measure of hypocrisy to that. And I'm sure they believe it, but the headmaster of Eton sees it as his role to raise students who will be morally better. And because they will go on to become the elites, not just in Britain, but around the world because it's an international school now, he sees Eton's mission rather in the sense that Henry VI did when he founded it as improving society, despite the fact that as it was back in the 15th century when Eton was founded, it's absolutely interlarded
伊顿公学，所有公立学校中最排外的，去殖民化其课程并强调公平，我真的看不出像伊顿这样排外的学校，你必须花一大笔钱才能进去。我的意思是，在某种程度上，大肆宣扬其对公平的承诺，这其中有一种虚伪。我相信他们相信这一点，但伊顿校长认为他的职责是培养在道德上更好的学生。而且因为他们将继续成为精英，不仅在英国，而且在世界各地，因为现在这是一所国际学校，他认为伊顿的使命更像是亨利六世创立它时的初衷，即改善社会，尽管事实上，正如伊顿创立时的15世纪一样，它绝对充满了
with hypocrisy and ambivalence that these are schools that are committed to the virtues of poverty and equality and whatever. But simultaneously, it's all about the prestige and the money and the status. Well, I'm sure if the head of Eton were here, he'd say it's not all about the prestige and the money and the status. Kind of is, though. You could also say, of course, that tension has run right through from the days of William of Wickham, Tom. But actually, that tension is the tension between idealism and worldliness that lies at the heart of any institution, not just at the heart of the Catholic Church, of the Church of England, of all these kinds of things, which they have great, sweeping, soaring ideals, but also they live in a real world that is governed
虚伪和矛盾，这些学校致力于贫困和平等的美德等等。但同时，这一切都是关于声望、金钱和地位。嗯，我相信如果伊顿校长在这里，他会说这并不全是关于声望、金钱和地位。不过确实有点像。你也可以说，当然，这种紧张关系从威廉·威克姆时代起就一直存在，汤姆。但实际上，这种紧张关系是存在于任何机构核心的理想主义与世俗之间的紧张关系，不仅存在于天主教会、英国国教、所有这些事物的心脏，它们有伟大的、宏大的、高耸的理想，但它们也生活在一个由
by more prosaic mercenary concerns. Yes, but I think that just as when William Wickham founds Winchester and it's couched in terms, I mean, he's modelling it on the disciples who were sent out by Jesus in the Gospel of Luke. I mean, that's a very, very high aspiration. But at the same time, he's taking bungs from supporters. You know, he's putting in wealthy pupils. I mean, that's a deliberate attempt to kind of go behind the show of moral behavior.
更平庸的唯利是图的担忧所统治的现实世界中。是的，但我认为就像威廉·威克姆创立温彻斯特时，它被用词包装，我的意思是，他以路加福音中耶稣派出的门徒为蓝本。我的意思是，那是一个非常、非常高的抱负。但与此同时，他从支持者那里拿回扣。你知道，他引入了富有的学生。我的意思是，那是一种刻意的尝试，试图掩盖道德行为的表象。
And I would say that Eton today is no different. I don't think that you can separate out claims to support equity while also trousering however many tens of thousands the fees cost, thereby making it impossible for most people to go to that school without there being a massive tension at the heart of it. Well, I think what you just do is you dish all the equity stuff, Tom. That's what I'd do. Well, I know. You know what I would do. I'd just go full reactionary. Sandbrook Towers. What about Harry Potter? So we have done Sherlock Holmes, James Bond. We must have done other cultural things. We did Agatha Christie. We did the Beatles, sort of avatars of Britishness by and large. So do you think that, I mean, I suppose the question about Harry Potter is how long... I would not have expected Harry Potter to
我会说今天的伊顿公学没有什么不同。我不认为你可以将对支持公平的诉求与同时赚取数万学费分离开来，从而使大多数人无法进入那所学校，而这其中没有巨大的紧张关系。嗯，我认为你所做的就是把所有公平的东西都抛弃，汤姆。那就是我会做的。嗯，我知道。你知道我会做什么。我会完全反动。桑德布鲁克大厦。哈利·波特怎么样？所以我们做了夏洛克·福尔摩斯、詹姆斯·邦德。我们一定做过其他文化事物。我们做了阿加莎·克里斯蒂。我们做了披头士乐队，大体上是英国性的化身。所以你认为，我的意思是，我想关于哈利·波特的问题是多久……我没想到哈利·波特会
have endured as successfully as it has. I marvel at the extraordinary power those stories have over children's imagination. I think it's a brilliant synthesis of all kinds of traditions that have a global resonance, British traditions. In that sense, it is absolutely a legacy from the age of British imperialism when the British Empire expanded a familiarity with concepts like King Arthur, public school stories, all that kind of stuff. And there are brilliant blendings of that to create something new. Yeah.
像它那样成功地持久。我惊叹于这些故事对儿童想象力的非凡力量。我认为它是所有具有全球共鸣的英国传统的精彩综合。从这个意义上说，它是大英帝国扩张时期留下的遗产，当时大英帝国扩展了对亚瑟王、公立学校故事等概念的熟悉。而且有精彩的融合创造了新的东西。是的。
So I was always very skeptical. As you know, I've dissed them a little bit in my book, The Great British Dream Factory. And then when The Sun and Air started reading them, I just was staggered. By that point, they were, what, 20 years old or something? I mean, I think it works as powerfully as it does because the theme of the novels is magic. And I think there is a kind of magic about what J.K. Rowling does in the Harry Potter stories. But it wouldn't work if it wasn't a school story. As you said in the last episode, the beauty of a school story is it gives you an institution, a closed environment,
所以我一直非常怀疑。如你所知，我在我的书《伟大的英国梦工厂》中稍微贬低了它们。然后当太阳和空气开始读它们时，我简直惊呆了。到那时，它们已经20岁左右了，对吧？我的意思是，我认为它之所以如此有力，是因为小说的核心主题是魔法。而且我认为J.K.罗琳在哈利·波特故事中所做的事情有一种魔法。但如果它不是一个学校故事，它就不会奏效。正如你在上一集所说，学校故事的美妙之处在于它给了你一个机构、一个封闭的环境、
a set of rules, an unchanging cast, all of those things, which are true of children's own lives. Of course. But also, as you said, I mean, you listed all the other, the kind of precursors of Hogwarts, Worst Witch and In the Light and whatever, but none of those have had the global resonance that Harry Potter has. And so I think that that's what I mean by the kind of the magic of it. There's a kind of indefinable quality that has made it unbelievably globally successful, and which enables it to retain its popularity in an age when often there are lots of people who are quite ideologically opposed to it. I mean, it doesn't seem to have had any impact on its sales or popularity at all.
一套规则、一个不变的演员阵容，所有这些事情，对于孩子们自己的生活来说都是真实的。当然。但正如你所说，我的意思是，你列出了所有其他的，霍格沃茨的前身，《最差女巫》和《在光中》等等，但没有一个像哈利·波特那样具有全球共鸣。所以我认为这就是我所说的魔法的含义。有一种难以定义的品质使它在全球范围内取得了令人难以置信的成功，并使它在许多人对其意识形态上相当反对的时代依然保持受欢迎。我的意思是，它似乎对其销量或受欢迎程度没有任何影响。
Well, I saw this clip on YouTube or Twitter or something a couple of days ago. So at the beginning of September every year, people assemble at King's Cross Station. Do you know this? And King's Cross Station do an announcement that the Hogwarts Express will be leaving from platform nine and three quarters, the beginning of the school year, Tom. And the King's Cross was rammed. There were hundreds of people. Were they all dressed in their school uniforms and broomsticks? I think some people were probably dressed. They were all filming the information boards,
嗯，几天前我在YouTube或Twitter上看到了这个片段。所以每年9月初，人们都会聚集在国王十字车站。你知道这个吗？国王十字车站发布公告说，霍格沃茨特快列车将从九又四分之三站台出发，学年开始，汤姆。国王十字车站挤满了人。有数百人。他们都穿着校服，拿着扫帚吗？我想有些人可能穿了。他们都在拍摄信息板，
recording the announcement. Hundreds and hundreds of people for whom clearly this is, dare I say, Tom, a sacral moment. But that must have been a day when there was a strike, I think. So it really was magic if a train was leaving King's Cross. Surely there are never strikes. There are never strikes on the Hogwarts Express. Right. Let's talk about what we have coming up next week.
录制公告。成百上千的人，对他们来说，这显然是，我敢说，汤姆，一个神圣的时刻。但那一定是在罢工的一天，我想。所以如果火车离开国王十字车站，那真是魔法。肯定从来没有罢工。霍格沃茨特快列车上从来没有罢工。好吧。让我们谈谈下周我们要讲的内容。
We are doing something very different, two very different subjects. So you, Tom, will be talking about gladiators. Yes, the Coliseum. So actually rather public school, people fighting each other and inflicting violence. And in a very different episode this time next week, we will be talking about the coup in Chile in 1973 that saw the end of the Allende government and the rise of General Pinochet. And on that, Bombshell Tom, thank you very much to everybody for listening. Bye-bye.
我们要讲一些非常不同的东西，两个非常不同的主题。所以你，汤姆，将谈论角斗士。是的，斗兽场。所以实际上相当公立学校，人们互相战斗并施加暴力。而在下周这个时候的另一集里，我们将谈论1973年智利的政变，那次政变见证了阿连德政府的终结和皮诺切特将军的崛起。关于这一点，重磅炸弹汤姆，非常感谢大家的收听。再见。
Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening
一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。